a very invention to me is taking
something all about yourself or your
industry and then applying and
sprinkling some new qualities about it
so for me it's about taking my polish
grit and resourcefulness and applying it
on a larger scale
so I think them one of the most pivotal
moments in my career was actually when I
first started I felt like this label of
being an investor meant I had to behave
a certain way and look at certain way
and I would show up in these conference
rooms mostly middle-aged people mostly
man and I felt like I had to do this
professional finance thing I tried and
then my very first performance review I
got pretty negative feedback around
being too quiet another pinyon I didn't
have and I'm a very opinionated and loud
person and so it was this moment of
trying to fake it and to fit in doesn't
work I should just be myself and so
embracing like my own true self in my
work whether it's through like my
outfits or to like how I approach
relationships with people however to
work and just doing my opinionated edgy
self has been made a world of difference
for me
[Music]
being one of the challenges that I
didn't appreciate when I first started
in private equity after college was that
it is fundamentally a people business
and people have all different approaches
and styles and personalities and so
making sure I adapt in still in a very
authentic way but depth to whoever I'm
working with whether it's different team
members where it's working with
different executives found there is just
every situation as their friend and
making sure embrace that the people part
of it and make myself as effective as
possible in a situation I think one of
the big things I hope happens in finance
is that we embrace the diversity of
people thought approaches etc and so for
me it's really important that I kind of
am one of the people in the industry
when younger investors coming up can see
that you don't have to be a certain way
or finger certain way because it
actually helps with performance but also
helps you just enjoy the job I think
it's when you are kind of doing your own
thing in your own way you enjoy it and
you're better at it and so making sure
that people think that this industry can
be for everyone and not just for a
certain cookie cutter person
[Music]
you